listing all the ways Avengers ends game
made us emotional would take forever
instead it will focus on just one
spoiler with an aspect of the superhero
ensemble that packed a heart-rending
punch a line little Morgan Stark told
her father Tony early on in the film and
the same one he repeated back to her at
the end reportedly Avengers end game
directors Joan Anthony Russo sat down
with watching Hollywood and explain the
origins of the adorable and impactful
line translated to English by the folks
at comic book calm the interview details
that the I Love You 3000 line came about
from Tony Stark actor Robert Downey jr.
the actor told the Russo brothers at one
of his sweet children told him they
loved him that much and the directors
found the story so sweet
but they couldn't resist incorporating
the line into endgame twice since this
explanation is said to have come
straight from the people in charge it
effectively shuts down all other
speculation fans stirred up around the I
Love You 3000 line some theorize that
the phrase Morgan told her father may
have been a clever throwback to him
mentioning tons when he told her how
much he loved her one u.s. turn equals
2,000 pounds and three thousands a bit
more than that figure another idea
Marvel Lights had was that the 3,000 of
the phrase is actually a nod to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as 3000's that
combines a number of minutes every
already released movie and they yet to
launch by demand far from home run four
figures from IMDB pin the MCU thus far
from Iron Man two Avengers endgame as
running for a total of two thousand
eight hundred and sixty-seven minutes
assuming that spider-man far from home
will match the 133 minute runtime of
spider-man homecoming that brings the
number up to three thousand I love you
three thousand as one of the two
unforgettable lines Tony Stark gave an
Avengers end game the other came at the
climax after Tony retrieves him Finity
stones from Thanos and locks him into
his own suit the mad Titan says I'm an
effort of all Thanos snaps his fingers
then looks shocked to see Tony wielding
the Infinity stones just as sanest his
line mirrors what he told the surviving
Avengers at the start of endgame Tony
gives an equally memorable callback when
he says I am Iron Man
truth is
I am Iron Man
while I love you 3000 was apparently
thought out in advance I am Iron Man was
a snap decision the Russo brothers
admitted during a Q&A session for
Avengers endgame that Tony's powerful
moments in the film wasn't included in
the script and didn't even make it into
the movie until the filmmakers were
editing according to the Russo's Tony
used to not say anything in that moment
and we were in the editing room going he
has to say something this is a character
who has lived and died by quips and we
just couldn't we tried a million
different lines Thanos was saying I'm
inevitable and I edit so Jeff Ford said
why don't we just go full circle with it
and say I am Iron Man Tony Stark began
the MCU as we know it with Iron Man and
he ended the franchise's 11-year saga
with Avengers and game his character arc
finally came to an emotional close when
he bravely sacrificed his life to ensure
the safety of the entire universe it's
only right that he was a messenger of
some of the hardest hitting lines in the
film and the hero who likely made
audiences openly weep in their theater
seats though he's gone for good
it's clear that fans will always love
him 3,000 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
you
[Music]